welcome to this video playing Frankie J
Frankie J from the US and in fact I now
know that there's a statistic here
sadistic function when which I never
used on as you see but I haven't now set
up that it always gives me an overview
of my score against those players so it
tells me I never played it before ok we
have an English opening and this is some
nice line for black I believe this is
some something else are played in
tournament chess black delays the night
development on bh to get a four center
if possible with t five to close to let
download e5 I always liked it too to
occupy the center with paws always feel
like I'm doing the right thing it's a
very classical approach to chance of
course but it's a matter of taste I
normally like it to have pawns in the
center okay yeah this is some a normal
way to to play for white a good way and
I continued to develop there should be
six 9797 I guess so
yeah I can't help it I like blech seems
like him I've got control him maybe I
can tickle him a bit on the Kings side
with age four okay let's do that we can
ask inside a bit I have four more pieces
near the king then he does I mean I
don't have an account but maybe I can
can drum up something
hmm
not sure what the smooth is doing I have
Quincy 83 day 495 that's probably not
hurting him this movement not sure that
it's really helping can play book a
seven queen bee eight maybe okay but
first let's take down the Sun should be
okay and queen b aj sense the rook back
what now how to get something going here
the bishop on g7 um could maybe here we
have maybe him
thinking about vaguely about things like
my cam queen bee 694 ok so he's
retreating
hmm
and I g4 you can you can just take take
on d5 but then no point be sexist
nonsense I could play Queen B 6 here
yeah let's let's do that and not to
spend spend ages Nyjah for the idea
okay yeah would be to as it's not doing
much but it's also not spoiling much aha
so he's opening up the position here
interesting
look be eight something rock PA I cannot
go to be one rook e8 to a one maybe
maybe this idea 9700 k 1 this is not not
good king age 200 something is also not
good coo coo coo crooked maybe
okay yeah hard to make any progress IAM
okay this this is a pin and this is also
a pin hmm
yeah I don't want to exchange need to
need to need any more pieces to keep the
pressure on I gave give a bit of ground
here Nigel increases the pressure
using the pin on age 61 okay ook ook ook
ook p6 probably with the temple the ship
c7 the 36 ok so i can take it now
yeah this is this is a strong bishop
he's got Nazi threesome but I five check
no one no made on anything Bishop she to
him okay time morning check check check
white forfeits on time yeah I really
like this game this was like slow grind
where I don't I didn't have much but
somehow then I got a little bit bit of
something it's not here not much what
was going on yeah this is helping me a
bit it's probably still equal but just
probing a bit and here it's it slightly
uncomfortable and here's think he makes
a mistake again after defy no no after
deform and better really better he
probably needs to do needs to go away
with the night something like that maybe
it doesn't allow the form yeah this
should be okay here I'm getting I'm
getting pressure I could have exchanged
but that didn't didn't want to want to
yon TI black black is winning I mean I
probably I didn't play it in the best
way but didn't have much time it felt
like it really should should be a shame
should be made almost but do Roxy once
it's even better yeah okay I didn't okay
rook see one he moved the knight to e
three days rick h one almost we cannot
go to you three yeah this is stronger
something like that there are various
ways to try for meteor even mmm yes
better you okay but i think it was it
was a very very much better for black
even with the with the way I played
alright thanks for watching